Did you know that in 2005
the Eiffel Tower in Paris was engulfed in flames for 29 consecutive hours?
this phenomenon which has yet to be explained by experts to this day
featured in a few photographs that were salvaged from the event
one notable aspect was the irregular ignition of the tower
which remained partially and completely engulfed in flames
causing fear and amazement among tourists
due to the extreme rarity of the situation
and the impossible of intervention due to the towers materials
even authorities were hesitant to get involved
the press did not cover this event to maintain calm in the country
and avoid potential complications
the only somewhat possible explanation
is related to so strange UFO sighting in the skies of Paris two days before